[Music]
first of all I know you're a big sports
fanatic you're also a guy that keeps up
on the news and there's there's big news
out there in the sporting world big news
is Oscar Pistorius yeah huge news and I
don't like him don't care for him never
did
really you don't like Oscar Pistorius
even before he what are you doing adds
nothing in my tube okay okay yeah I
didn't you're saying I mean a lot of
people don't like him now that he a lot
but but allegedly but also really yeah
but yeah I don't have problems with the
murder right that's what I never like I
never liked him racing with them things
that look like seven Wiley coyote would
order and Wes well they weren't a
problem with him racing with his rage
his blades he was the Blade Runner
yes lawn blade I did have a big problem
with it because I'll put it this way
let's imagine you're a runner and you
know with legs yeah
and then you go home there you go oh I
lost honey who'd you lose to guy with no
legs wait wait you're saying that you
didn't like it
Oscar Pistorius raced against people
with legs no I don't I feel that one of
the basic requirements of being a
sprinter is having leg I feel that they
should say okay listen let's say here's
the - hey what about you I don't think
you could be on the team why not well
you you have you're not a biped you have
no legs so scram
okay take your time as long as you want
but get the hell out of here no one's
going with you on this nobody is with
you on this all except the feller at
home that's like--that's that son of a
[ __ ] I lost my race dude that got no
legs are you seeing an unfair advantage
cuz he had these well of course he had
the rocket ships they're not ships okay
help me out here no he still had still
him running yeah yes well guys I agree
with you that Oscar Pistorius is a
scholar and a gentleman
here's a murderer
it lets murderer